of the concepts which are there of the
Tokamak is by far the most mature in
terms of its breadth of performance and
um and thinking about how it would be
applied in a Fusion Energy System in the
history of this was that many in fact
you asked what if we go back to the
history of the palestine's infusion
center the history of fusion is that
people
scientists had started to work on this
in the 1950s it was all hush-hush and
you know Cold War and all that kind of
stuff and and it's like they realized
holy cow there's like this is like
really hard like we actually don't
really know like what we're doing in
this because everything was at low
temperatures they couldn't get
confinement it was interesting and then
the the they Declassified it and this is
one of the few places that the the west
and the Soviet Union actually
collaborated on was the science even
during the Cold War even during the
middle of the Cold War it was really and
this actually perpetuates all the way
till now for we we can talk about the
the project that that is sort of
captured in now
um
uh but and and the reason they
Declassified it is because like
everything like kind of like sucked
basically you know about trying to make
this confinement and high temperature
plasma and then the Russians then the
Soviets right came along with this
device called the Tokamak which is a
Russian acronym which basically means
magnetic coils arranged in the shape of
a donut and
and um they said holy holy cow like
everyone was stuck at like a meager like
half a million degrees or half a million
degrees which is like in Fusion terms of
zero basically
um and then they come along they say oh
we've actually achieved a temperature 20
times higher than everybody else and
it's actually started to make fusion
reactions and everyone just go oh you
know no way it's just hype from this
it's like there's no way because we
failed at this
um it's a great story in the history of
fusion is that then but this insisted
and said no look you can see this from
our data it's like this thing is really
hot and it seems to be working this is
you know late 1960s and there was a uh
there was a team that went from the
United Kingdom's Fusion development lab
and they brought this very fancy amazing
new technology called the laser
and they use this laser and they shot
the laser beam like through the plasma
and by looking at the scattered light
that came from the they go that
basically the scattered light gets more
broadened in its Spectrum if it gets
hotter so you could you could exactly
tell the temperature of this and even
though you're not physically touching
the plasma it's like holy cow you're
right it is like it is 10 million
degrees and so this was one of those
explosions of like everyone in the world
then wanted to build a token Mac because
it was clearly like wow this is like so
far ahead of everything else that we
tried before
um so that actually has a part of the
the story to MIT in the Plato science
infusion center was
why is there a strong Fusion in a major
Fusion program at MIT it was because we
were host to the Francis bitter magnet
laboratory which is also the National
High field magnet laboratory well you
can see where this goes right from this
you know we're kind of telling the
stories backwards almost but you know
the the the Advent of a Toca Mac along
with the fact that you could makes very
strong magnetic fields with the
technology that had been developed at
that laboratory that was the origins of
sort of pushing together the physics of
the of the plasma containment and the
magnet technology and put them together
in a way that I would say is you know a
very typical MIT success story right we
don't do just just pure science or pure
technology we sort of set up this
intersection between them and there were
several Pioneers that of of my of the of
people at MIT like Bruno copy who's a
professor in the physics department and
Ron Parker who was a professor in
electrical engineering and nuclear
engineering it's like even the makeup of
the people right has got this blends of
Science and Engineering in them and
that's actually was the origin of the
plaza science infusion center was was
doing those things so anyway so back to
this so why so yes tokamax have been
have achieved the highest in magnetic
Fusion by far like the the the best
amounts of these of these conditions
that I had talked about and in fact
pushed right up to the point where they
were near QP of one they just didn't
quite get over one so can we actually
just Linger on the uh on the
collaboration across different nations
just um yeah maybe looking at the
philosophical aspect of this
even in the Cold War
there's something hopeful to me besides
the energy that these giant
International projects
are
a really powerful way to ease some of
the geopolitical tension even military
conflict across Nations there's a
war in Ukraine
and Russia
there's a brewing tension and conflict
with China just the world is still
um seeking military conflict cold or hot
um what can you say about sort of the
lessons of the 20th century and these
giant projects uh in their ability to
ease some of this tension
so it's it's a great question so as I
said there was a reason because it was
so hard that was one of the reasons they
they Declassified it um and actually
they started working together in some
sense on it as well too and I think it
was really there was
you know and are you ristic or or
altruistic
um aspect to this it's like this is
something that could change you know the
future of humanity and its nature and
its relationship with energy isn't this
something that we should work on
together right and and and that went
along in those ones and in particularly
that any kind of place where you can
actually have an open exchange of of of
people who are sort of at the
intellectual frontiers of your Society
this is a good thing right of being able
to collaborate I've I've had the I mean
I've had have had an amazing you know
career I've worked with people from it's
like hard to throw a dart at a country
and on the map and not hit a country of
people that I've been able to work with
how amazing is that and and even just
getting small numbers of people to
bridge the cultural and societal
societal uh um you know divides is a
very important thing even when it's a
very teeny action of the overall
populations it can be held up as as an
example of that but it's interesting
that if you look at then that continued
collaboration which continues to this
day is that it was it this actually
played a major role in fact in East-West
relations or like so Soviet West
relations Is that
um back in the uh the Reagan Gorbachev
days which of course were interesting in
themselves of all kinds of changes
happening you know on both sides right
um and but still like a desire to you
know push down the stockpile of nuclear
weapons and all that within that context
there was
um a very fairly significant historic
event that at one of the the Reagan
Gorbachev Summits is that they had
really they they didn't get there like
they couldn't figure out how to bargain
to the point of the of the the some some
part of the treaty I can't remember the
details of it anymore
but they needed some kind of a symbol
almost to say but we're still going to
keep working you know towards something
that's important for all of us whether
they pick a fusion project
and that was in the mid-1980s and
actually then after so they basically
signed an agreement that they would move
forward to like literally collaborate on
on a project whose idea would be to show
large net energy gain infusions
commercial viability and work together
on that and very soon after that Japan
joined as did the European Union and now
um that project it evolved over a long
period of time and had some interesting
political ramifications to it but in the
end this actually also had South Korea
India and China join as well too so
you're talking about make major
a major fraction of and now Russian of
course instead of the Soviet Union
um and actually that Coalition is
holding together despite the obvious
political you know uh turmoil that's
going around on all those things and
that's a project called eter which is in
under construction in the south of
France right now